BEGIN.
WOLF WAIT A FEW MORE MINUTES TWO
MORE MINUTES FOR THE REST OF THE
MEMBERS TO BE HERE [inaudible]
SO FAR.
SHARE PUBLIC SAFETY IS HERE
[inaudible]
AND COM LIBRARY DOVE IS HERE.
WE NEED MORE MEMBERS TO GET A
QUORUM SO WE CAN GET TO BUSINESS
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND MR STONE IS HERE SO IT LOOKS
LIKE HE'LL BE THE FIRST TO GO
.
SINCE MR LACKEY IS HERE WILL
BEGIN THE SUBCOMMITTEE --
ASSEMBLY.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL NOW
BEGIN WILL START WITH SO
[inaudible]
IT'S JUST DOWN ASSEMBLY BILL --
TWELVE FOURTEEN READ.
THE WELFARE AND INSTRUCTIONS CHO
REALLY TO JUVENILES YOU MAY
BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL.
MAY LOOK VERY FAMILIAR.
THIS WAS PASSED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
ESSENTIALLY AND WAS VETO BY THE
GOVERNOR UNFORTUNATELY.
WHAT THE BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS IS JUVENILE COMPETENCY
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PROCESSES WHEN ADD
ADULTS IS A JUDGE TO BE
ENCUMBERED STAND TRIAL?
BUT NOT THE SAME LEVEL OF
PROTECTIONS OUR PROCEDURES FOR
JUVENILES AND THE EFFECT IS THAT
YOU LAWS AND UP LANGUISHING IN
JUVENILE HALL FOR YEARS
SOMETIMES BECAUSE WE'RE NOT.
ABLE TO FORCE THE SITUATION TO
GET THOSE KIDS A SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED.
THEY MAY BE UNDER AGE IN THE
CHORE.
THEY MAY BE SUFFERING
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS BE ANY
NUMBER OF REASONS THAT THEY'RE
NOT READY TO STAND TRIAL BUT IT
IS CRUEL TO HOLD THEM IN
JUVENILE HALLS WHICH ARE NOT
EQUIPPED.
FOR WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
PROBATION OFFICERS PRETTY
CLOSELY ON THIS BILL NOW THE
GOVERNOR WAS CONCERNED ABOUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND SO THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME AS THE BE
NINE THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR.
BUT WE'RE EXTENDING THE TIMELINE
FOR YOUTH WHO BEEN ACCUSED OF
SEVERAL.
SEVENTY CRIMES WHICH ARE SOME OF
THE MORE SERIOUS CRIMES THAT
WASN'T AN ISSUE.
AND WE'RE REQUIRING THE COURT TO
CONSIDER SPECIFIC ITEMS FOR
COMMUNITY ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION WHEN THEY ARE
DEALING WITH THESE.
WITH THESE YOUTH THOSE CHANGES I
IT'S ON THIS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING PRETTY CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH OPPOSITION
AND OTHERS WE PUT THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU WHAT I ASK FOR YOUR I
DON'T.
THANK YOU IN NEW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YES SAID JIM SALLY WHEN THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER SAMOS
PERSONAL COUNTY AND PRESIDENT OF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR PROBATION
BECAUSE WE ARE THE ENTITY TASK
WITH HOUSING THESE INCOMPETENT
YOUTH IN OUR JUVENILE HALLS.
AND WE ARE AT POWERLESS TO GET
THEM OUT TO MOVE THEM ONTO A
SAFER MORE --
PROPER SETTING THE JUVENILE HALL
SO WE WOULD URGE YOU TO TO VOTE
FOR A ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE I ASK HERE EITHER.
THANK YOU --
THAT'S WHAT WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM OTHER CHAIR WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE AND A
FREE WITNESSES FOR COMING TODAY.
NOW HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON --
ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE NINE EIGHT MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
NOT THAT I DO ANY OF THOSE
THINGS [inaudible]
HER BILL.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WERE
SAYING I THINK WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM SO ONE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
EGGMAN SECTOR CALL THE ROLL
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
CARILLO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK SANTIAGO.
BOTH THE PRESIDENT THE END OF
THE ALPHABET IS NOT HERE BUT
HOPEFULLY WILL BE HERE SOON.
THANK YOU VERY BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT A BILL
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AB.
NINE NINETY EIGHT THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND THE PROVEN MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OR MTT MODEL
OF VIOLENCE TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION TO INCLUDE SITUATIONS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CALIFORNIA'S HUMAN TRAFFIC
CALIFORNIA IS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOT SPOT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE WERE MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED CASES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING OVER ONE THOUSAND SEX
TRAFFICKING CASES.
THE STATISTICS ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE EQUALLY SOBERING
THE CDC'S NATIONAL INTIMATE
PARTNER AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
SURVEY FOUND THAT 32% OF WOMEN
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIM OF VIOLENCE.
SEXUAL VIOLENCE WERE STALKING BY
AN INTIMATE PARTNER THIS RATE
EXCEEDS THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN
RESPONSE TO THESE DISTURBING
TRENDS CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AUTHORIZED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS.
THERE ARE THEY GOT BEES ARE
MULTI AGENCY MULTI DISCIPLINARY
CENTERS THAT ALLOW VICTIMS TO
ACCESS ALL NEEDED SERVICES IN
ONE LOCATION AND TO ENHANCE
VICTIM SAFETY AND INCREASE
OFFENDER ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHILE EXISTING LAW ALLOWS FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER PERSONNEL TO
SHARE CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
AMONGST THEMSELVES NOT EVERY
COUNTY HAS AND THAT J. C. OR THE
RESOURCES TO ESTABLISH.
ONE THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND ONLY TWENTY ONE
AFTER A SEIZE.
AB NINE NINETY EIGHT WILL
AUTHORIZE CITIES COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO ESTABLISH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING MBTS.
THAT AUTHORIZES MEMBERS OF THOSE
TEAMS TO DISCLOSE TO ONE ANOTHER
INFORMATION AND RECORDS THAT MAY
BE CONFIDENTIAL BUT THAT IS A
RELEVANT TO THE PREVENTION
IDENTIFICATION MANAGEMENT.
AND OR TREATMENT OF THESE CRIMES.
THESE TEAMS WILL CONSIST OF
PERSONNEL WHO ARE TRAINED IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF DUBBED OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES AND WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO
PROVIDE A BROAD RANGE OF
SERVICES RELATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM IS
AN ESTABLISHED A MODEL FOR
ASSISTING INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES STRUGGLING WITH
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE AB NINE
NINETY EIGHT WILL ALLOW COUNTIES
BOTH WITH AND WITHOUT FTA SEES.
TO COOPERATE AND LEVERAGE
RESOURCES FOR THE VULNERABLE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
ALSO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
STEVEN CENTRALIZED DIRECTOR FOR
MISTER GRAYSON HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE A WITNESS AND IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE WAS AGGRESSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVATE.
THANK YOU CHAIRS RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE.
OR NEED MOST.
ON AB NINE NINE EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO BE CONCURRED IN.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARDIO.
CARDIO I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY QUIRK
SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURES CONCURRED.
THANK YOU JEFF.
YES WE DO. FOR AB TWELVE
FOURTEEN MISTER STONE'S BILL.
ON AB TWELVE FOURTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO BE CONCURRED IN
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE GABRIELLE.
EVERY YOLK AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
QUIRK SOME.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE GREAT COURAGE AND WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OF BEEN FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NO
YES.
ON AB NINE I NAY KILEY.
YOU MISTER GRACE OF BILL
[inaudible]
KILEY AYE.
ON TWELVE FOURTEEN KILEY
.
KILEY NOT VOTING
I'M SORRY SIR
DO YOU NOT ON THE AGENDA
.
NOT LIKE ME.
I'M HERE.
ON AB NINE NINE EIGHT SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
BUT AB TWELVE FOURTEEN SANTIAGO
THANK YOU WITH THAT BACK
CONCLUSIVE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE